Hey, what's going on is bill burn
his time for the Thursday afternoon?
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and
Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you like a friend,
like a pal, just calling to say
hello. You know what I mean?
You know when somebody calls
just to say air quote hello.
And you know as much as you sitting there
going, oh, you want to believe it? Uh,
this is so nice. He's just saying hello.
The thing is the first seven minutes,
the first seven minutes, she got to be on
pins and needles. Like, when's it coming?
When's it coming?
When's the favor going to be asked?
I never hear from this motherfucker.
And now he's called, Hey,
just called to see what's going
on, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And they wind their fucking way around.
They dosey doe year round the room.
You're like, wow, isn't this
nice? He just called to say hello.
He's really asking me how I'm
doing and my wife are doing.
And then all of a sudden Eric comes star.
That's great. You know? Interesting.
You should say that because dude,
I could use your boat.
I could use about two grand.
You know, I know what's a lot,
I'm embarrassed to even ask
you, but like I just, you know,
I hit a little bit of a rough patch.
I'll get it back to you probably by
the end of the month or maybe never.
Worst case scenario, I'll never
bring it up again, but when you do,
I'll make it seem like you're
the asshole. Like, really?
You're going to do this now.
You're going to do this now in front of
my family that they're not here, dude,
they left you years ago. Oh, then
you're going to bring that up. You know,
one of those fucking guys, no matter
what you do, somehow you're the Douche.
Samiah you're the one at fault.
You know that works. People,
you know, they, they don't
take responsibility for
themselves, like make, you know,
I'm a fucking pillar of this community.
That's when you know it's time to move.
If I'm saying that type of shit and you
live anywhere near me. Um, so guess what?
MMM, my old ass kitchen. My
old ass fucking kitchen yeah.
Is uh,
they started to work on it today.
So we rented a small house around
the corner because last time,
longtime listeners, you know, we fucking
ended up getting like smoker coughs.
You can't live in a house where they're
doing demolition. You just can't.
I've done it twice. I did
it once in New York. Um,
once again, I was putting a
kitchen and it was the ugly,
the kitchen I had was the ugliest fucking
kitchen you've ever seen in your life.
The cabinets were like this,
um, you know, like when,
when they try to have
like the flesh color of a,
of a slightly less pasty person
than me, you know, that color.
It's not white. It's
not peach. It's not 10.
It's just that fucking color.
It was that color counters and cabinets.
And then it was a dark brown outline
on the cabinets with that far.
It was like,
you know,
when they make a doll and it's
supposed to be a Caucasian doll,
like back in the day you remember that?
Fuck it was that fun. Oh, that's perfect.
Minus the rosy cheeks.
It was that color, right?
Like the color that thinks fucking foot.
I had a doll foot colored kitchen
was shit brown and I mean Shit Brown.
Okay.
Yeah, no shit. Fucking brown.
Jesus Christ. You're an animal.
Shit Brown outline around the cabinet.
And then I had this
fucking stove that like,
I swear to God was from like
the Serpico era of New York.
MMM.
And I want to say the walls were yellow,
like the used to be a sun yellow and
then that basically over the years faded
into your dreams have died in,
this is your lot in life yellow.
Um,
and you know,
I could barely afford
to get the kitchen done,
so I had to be there and I was in a
one bedroom apartment and they did the
ceiling to floor fucking plastic
shit. It, it means it gets most of it,
but the rest of it goes right
into your fucking lungs. I mean,
it just took for fucking ever.
Um,
uh,
but when it was done, it was the
shit, oh, it was finally fucking done.
But I remember,
you know what they forgot to do,
they forgot to give me a little place
to put a wastebasket and you're like,
oh fuck.
And then they just,
Jerry rigged this fucking horse shit that
never made sense. I never even used it.
And I lost a little cabinet space,
which is crucial in any kitchen.
Forget about when you got a little ass
fucking one bedroom apartment in New York.
So the next time I did anything
and you know, left New York,
sold the old digs, came
out here, you know,
went back to rent and then got a fucking
house and we did the whole downstairs,
which turned into a fucking nightmare
because my house is a 93 years old at this
point.
MMM.
So we had all kinds of cloth wiring.
We had all sense galvanized pipe.
We had a gas leak. We
just, every fuck we did.
At one point they were rodents in the
wall. So when we took the wall out,
there was a bunch of
road in Shit in the wall.
You know,
when they listed that thing
and I went to buy it, they did.
They didn't say that they, they,
they, they didn't disclose that.
You don't have to disclose to
the prospective buyer that, oh,
by the way,
we had some sort of mouse or rat problem
and they ate through the fucking walls
and they shit wherever they
wanted to, shit in. It was just,
it was literally a shit show.
So that took a fucking year to undo.
The whole downstairs was completely
fucked up, not up to code on.
I took the whole fucking year to get
that fixed and now that's fixed, so,
okay.
And then upstairs they'll fucking jumped.
The floors were warped.
I,
if you put a marble on my floor,
it would roll as fast as that
thing that chased Indiana Jones.
Like that's how fucking walk day where
that giant fucking ball, you know.
Um, by the way, that's the only Scifi type
movie. I can handle it. Cause you know,
it was weird. It was like science
fiction, but it was like back in the day,
you know,
so there was still like people's,
there were people walking around with
like fucking 0.8 years and uh, you know,
grabbing you by your fucking Scapula
and then for some reason pass out,
even though it makes no fucking sense
whatsoever. That's a Vulcan nerve.
What? I mean there's nerves everywhere.
What exactly is there? Fuck.
Is that dude's name Spock?
Right?
Did he have a last name
or was that not logical?
You fucking Douche with your mo from the
three stooges haircuts, unit, Fullan.
Anybody. Right. And your diva
fucking eyebrows. I too was a fraud.
Okay.
Anyways, the fuck I started talking about
Spock. No, I bit my fucking kitchen.
So today,
today was a big day,
so he moved into the little
fucking small place. Right. And uh,
you know, just grab clothes
and Shit, you know, that's it.
Bottle of booze. I hate to say that I
actually packed up a bottle of booze.
I mean, Bill, how many fucking
red flags do you need to see? Um,
I took that thing with me like,
Ooh,
I got to bring that like
I forgot my checkbook. Um,
I to tell you it was delicious. Delicious.
A little bourbon called Yippy Kai. Yay.
Not Mother Fucker for all your diehard
fans. Just Ki Yay. Might be a whiskey.
I don't even know. All I know is
when you poured into the glass,
you can't put a fucking ice cube in it
because it's just that fucking beautiful.
It would be. It would, it
would be absolutely religious.
Um, and my wife's fucking texting,
calling me right now. What is the problem?
What is the problem? I heard you
pull up. I can't figure out the keys.
Youth. I sense that you're
laying down enjoying yourself.
Is there any way you could
get up and not be relaxed?
All right, here we go. Doing podcast.
Oh, I can't do that. That's
too blunt. What's up?
All right. All right. What's
up? What should I go with?
Qt. Let's go with sweetie.
Sweetie. Pies. That too much. Is that
too pandering? Want to go with sweetie?
Question Mark? No. Emoji emojis
for, for fucking voice, right?
Real men. Don't Emoji. All right. They
take that big fucking deviled egg,
Eaton thumbs, and they try to, they did.
They do the best they can. I use emojis.
My favorite thing to do is to use emojis
with another man who fucking for some
reason we'll get like
homophobic if you send them one,
you know,
and once you sense that on them,
you just keep sending more and more
emojis and you gradually build your way up
that the, the little fucking smiley
face that's blowing the kiss.
That's a little hard,
you know?
Um, anyways, so we fucking um,
where guesthouse, Dunno. What
the fuck are we talking about?
Oh, Jesus Christ. What the fuck does
it matter where the fuck I'm doing it?
Okay.
Guest House. You mean garage? They're
always trying to fucking hook shit up.
No fucking downstairs.
She's out in the driveway.
All right. Anyways, um,
okay.
Plowing ahead. Why? Why, why would you
answer it bill? Why would you answer it?
When am I going to learn that?
You just don't fuck an answered and
then they'll be like, where were you?
What were you doing when you see them?
Then you just get it all out and it's
so easy to s much easier to say it.
Then the fried try to fucking texts if
forget about that whole voice message
saying they'd always ends up fucking
something up, especially pronouns.
So whenever it makes any sense that there
or maybe I'm a mumble. And Jack, I said,
I'll tell you right now who could
not voice text is Shannon Sharpe.
Jesus Christ.
I dunno who's hard to understand him.
It understand is him or that fucking
guy will pick me up in Scotland.
Bull Bull. Bull Bull. Well yeah,
but futbol.
Whoa.
Okay. You're looking at me. I don't know
what yeah, you literally talking to me.
Yup,
I'll follow.
MMM. Anyway, so today was the
first day that they did the, uh,
okay.
Did the fucking, the
demolition for the fucking, um,
the kitchen. Right. So I go
over there, cause you know,
I gotta get some mail and
I forgot some dumb shit,
like mouthwash and shit like that.
So I went over there to go get the
mail and all that crap and I, dude,
I went in there and it's
unfucking believable.
Yeah,
it's unreal how long it takes to build
a kitchen, but to take one apart.
I mean these guys,
they were down to the tile.
Shit was just gone and this is what
was killing me. It was, you know,
cause it's all grout and
all that type of shit.
Like I was downstairs getting
the mouthwash and I heard
him upstairs like Bam,
Bam, Bam, Bam. It's like I have
to get the fuck outta here. You,
you don't want to hear that
sound ever in your house.
I just kept picturing these old
revolutionary war nails coming out of like
fucking, what do they call that? Uh,
okay.
Support beams.
What do they call them?
The main thing like you can't fuck with
that wall because that wall is a load
bearing wall coming out. One
of the load bearing walls. Um,
so anyways, allegedly it's going
to take eight weeks. So, uh,
what's the over under on that guys?
Come on. It's football season.
Okay.
I'll tell you right now, like
the, if, if you had a bet,
the over under on a home
improvement project,
if you went to bed on that Vegas like
the fucking over would be off the charts.
You, you'd have to bet a
thousand to make a buck
and the under would be pro.
Well they never give you that go to odds,
but you know what I
mean. Um, so anyways, uh,
that shit began today. Um,
and we'll finally going to,
we're going to fix everything
because we had, you know,
oh you can see the kitchen in the pie
crust making video and you'll see me on
this little island.
And that was back when I having an
island was list this thing to have in a
kitchen and whether you had the space or
not and we completely did not have the
space and none of it made sense.
They had to sync up against the
wall and set up against the windows.
The stove instead of being up on the wall
against the wall was like the size of
like, I mean, I could barely get
a fucking cookie sheet in there.
And you guys know how I like
the sweet staff. So, uh,
they're finally getting rid of all that.
They're going to open it up a little
bit, uh, hopefully. And uh, you know,
it's not the biggest kitchen, but
I would just like to, you know,
like have shit work and I'd have some
big fat fuck hippo of an island in the
middle, push it up against the wall. The,
so they're getting rid of everything.
By the way.
They,
the last people who fucking put the
kitchen and rather than doing it the right
way and digging up the old floor,
they just put the tile on top of
the old floor. You know, that thing.
Let's just keep fucking building on
top of Shit. That's fucked up. Right?
So, um, and then that we had
this beautiful swinging door,
like this old school servant door back
when people had people coming over
cooking. I'm not talking slavery here.
I don't to make people uncomfortable.
I'm talking just indentured servants.
These are white people coming over.
The latest group of white
people from a Europe, we'll say,
we'll say this is a
politically correct house.
They only had a same colored
indentured servants. Right.
So when they raised the floor,
they had that, they cut the door,
they cut it up top and it just kills me
because I want to keep the fucking door.
But this guy's claiming that there's a
lot of doors like that around here cause
a lot of people read them the houses.
So hopefully I can get one that fits.
So I'm taking,
I'm having them take it off the fucking
tile and underneath that I'm guessing is
a hardwood kitchen floor that has now
been fucked up because of this tile and
all the glue and shit that they put on it.
So taking that up right
down to the plywood, which I
know is rotted the fuck out.
I know it is because when we
put a pantry in there, I could,
when we got down to the plywood,
I literally could have,
like if I gave a karate instruction
with that you guys would want to take my
class would be like Jesus Christ.
How did you punch through four
layers of fucking plywood? Well,
I let it marinate for 23
years under water, 23 years,
I mean since 1923 anyways,
so they're going to pull all of that
shit up and just get it down to whatever
you call the,
the braces and then they're going to
look down there and if there's any wiring
that's fucked up, if there's any
pipes of fucked up that taking it out,
they're not going around the
shit that taken it all out.
And then they're putting it in and
doing it the right fucking way.
And I'm telling you, I'm telling you,
whoever gets this house after me,
all right, I don't know how
long I'm going to stay there.
Whoever gets his fucking house after me,
you're not going to have to do shit unless
I stay in it so long that the fucking
kitchen goes out of style or some shit.
But whatever.
All I know is when you go into the
walls, it's going to have done right. Um,
I don't know.
I don't have that fucking in me.
I don't have it in me to just sort
of half ass something. You know,
people do that today. It's just
bricks and mortar. Fuck the next guy.
Why would you do that to him?
What if he's a good shit? Right?
What if he's a good freckled fuck like me?
You know what I mean?
He just going to stick me with
that. She can't. Um, so anyways,
that's what's happening today.
Uh, tomorrow I'm going to,
I'm flying out to Durham,
North Carolina to do a three nights of
shows with the FEC and former front man
of a rock band for 20 years.
Dean del Rey turned comedian, uh,
one of the great guys in standup
comedy. Uh, and I'm psyched because,
uh, you know, he's been
dropping all kinds of weight.
That's the kind of person I want to be
around. And uh, you know, he, you know,
he's like all those rock stars. He's
fucking sober. You know what I mean?
They all get fucking stories and
doing heroin with law. You know,
the lead singer of fucking whoever,
pick a fucking pen.
I don't want to say heroin.
Whatever.
They did blow with the fucking
guy from quiet, right? Kevin?
Dobro rest, his soul rest
is fucking sold in. Um,
so I got that going on.
But last night,
last night I sat in with the fucking band.
And uh,
it was funny because I told you when I,
when I went over to, uh, I was in Italy,
I was just,
you know,
I was jet lagged and I always end up
stumbling on some sort of fucking shit on
youtube.
Like the first time I went over to Europe,
since I've been doing the podcast,
I somehow stumbled upon somebody who
had uploaded all four of the Pittsburgh
Steelers first four wins in the Superbowl,
the games in their entirety.
And I just sat and watched and I,
I binged watch him cause I was afraid
the NFL was going to take them down.
And um, every time I go over there,
I find something fucker just,
I just end up in some weird part of the
fucking Internet where I find something
cool. And I ended up
gutting across, uh, I dunno,
it was just thinking about back in the
day somebody had asked a question about
like me taking drum lessons and
Hawaii who I studied with and a,
and now I used to,
I was used to be at this music
store that was in downtown Brockton.
I don't even know if it's there anymore
that was yet another victim of a guitar
center. But, uh,
that reminded me that one of the
big drums are, they was that, uh,
Bobby Shoe and art, I'm saying his name
right Chouinard, will you say it? And um,
and I was like,
he used to play for Billy Squier and I
started watching [inaudible] wire and
that was like, this fucking guy
was great. It's a great front man.
He's sort of straddled the
line of fucking rock band.
Pop Band did a great, and even the video
that they said, you know, took him down.
If you close your eyes, that was a
hit song in the 80s total hit song.
They just said the wrong video.
And unfortunately they didn't
have another hit after that.
So that's the last thing everybody
remembers, right? Your last season.
You only good as your last game.
Right? So anyways, long story short,
a friend of mine
hit me up and he mentioned
he was doing a show,
uh, Frankie Perez. Um, who,
if you guys ever saw that time,
I got to sit in with Dave Kush during
a couple of his buddies, wink, wink,
and play highway to hell.
Um,
he was the lead singer's guys just
like a fucking amazing singer.
So he mentioned that he was going to be
down at the, there's a bowling alley.
The fuck is it giving,
I'd never know the names of places.
It's right on Hollywood boulevard.
Right,
right around the corner from
where they do the Os. Yes. And uh,
so he said his band was
playing. I was like, yeah,
I'd love to go down and fucking see
you play or whatever, Yada, Yada, Yada.
And then he goes, hey man, you want
to sit in or a song? And I told you,
that's my fucking rule. I don't
force my Hollywood, my Hollywood.
I don't fault my Hollywood. I
don't force my hobby. Jesus Christ.
There's a fucking Freudian slip.
I don't force my ego,
I don't force my hobby on you. But if
you ask me, I was, I'm gonna say yes.
I don't give a shit how terrifying this
situation is. I'm going to say yes.
So I go, all right, well we'll figure
out this song. I said, by the way,
man, this guy is way better
than people remember.
And I sent them this Billy squire,
the lonely is the night.
And then he wrote back, he goes, dude,
I fucking love that guy cause
you want to do that song.
And that just struck me as funny. I
was like, yeah, let's fucking do it.
Everybody's always play an ACDC Zeplin
and all that shit. I'm like, fuck it,
let's do it. Um, so then I was
texting my other buddies saying,
yeah man, we're going to do lonely night
by Billy Squier. And they were all like,
ah,
that's an interesting choice
by knew Frankie was going to kill it.
So anyways,
so I go down there and he just
has this fucking monster band,
monster fucking band, a players like
this sitting at tuning up to play.
And they were going to do a cover of dazed
and confused and the other bands like,
you know,
load in this shit and just a guitar player
played the first sort of notes of the
song.
And I don't mean like the baseline,
I just mean some of the licks and he
had a telecast. It just like Jimmy had,
you know,
when he first came over here and played
at the whiskey and I was just like,
oh fuck, are they gonna do dazed
and confused? And then he fucking,
he see breaks out the boat and I swear
to God, man, it sounded like the album.
Then the whole band kicks in.
And, uh, the woman on drums,
Valerie Franco, right? She,
there's like a house drunk kid.
She says, you know, get that shit out
of the act. Puts in her own fucking kid.
She's got a vista like kit,
you know, like, what do they
call it, the candy striped,
um, vintage one. They start miking it
up. It sounds fucking unbelievable.
And I'm listening to a play
and I'm going like, Oh shit,
I got to go on after that. Like, you know,
they're going to pass off one
song to me after she plays. Right.
This is just the sound check.
Um,
I didn't realize that she was only
going like 40%. Uh, I'm actually good.
I tweeted a video of her playing a
cover to a mute math of all people.
Um, and I heard that she's going to
be doing something with Darren King,
that drummer. But dude, I gotta tell
you when that fucking show started,
the woman that I saw at sound
check was, was like, it was,
it was not the same person. And I was
blown away by the sound check though.
She fucking destroyed,
fucking destroyed. She,
the set began. She just hit the symbols
like twice. And I was like, what the fuck?
It sounded better than
anything I've played 20 years.
Absolutely fucking was murdering on the
drums and what it was common time for me
to play the song I was sitting in,
I was literally getting
the same butterflies I used
to get way back in the day
when I first started doing standup and
there was somebody killed it on stage and
I was just stuck.
Comedians know this,
we're all of a sudden you feel like
you're two inches tall going like,
I can't follow that. So,
uh, she gets off right?
They finished think murders it for six,
seven songs,
and then she comes back,
hands me the sticks. She just
like, all right, you're up.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah,
yeah, no problem. Right?
So I sit down and we go to play it at
the whole fucking thing went great.
Except I fucked up one major part.
Right?
Like the guitar riff Bannon and then
Annette is a part where the whole band
drops out and the guitar
plays, right. Donna? None.
And then on the snare and the floor,
Tom,
you and the bass player at Saint Tango
took, okay, good. Just like that data.
Then Annette Bannon a nun.
And a right.
I fucking forgot to do that part.
So the guitar player,
a total rock star goes bad.
Alan, Alan, that miss my cue.
And then so it's just the bass player
going boo boo boo boo boo boo boo boop.
I felt like fuck such a fucking asshole.
I think I literally said oops.
Like if anybody for whatever reason you
know was filming during that, you know,
everybody's got the fucking iPhones. If
anybody, you might even see me say oops.
But I don't think anybody noticed cause
I think most of the crowd was like what
fucking song is this? Um,
but it ended up going, I was,
I was nervous about the, the first part
because the first time they drop out,
you know,
he does all this simple barks and a
couple of nods to bottom there and those
things went off without a hitch. So
then you start, dude, it's all like,
I've found a few times ever sat and
with Ben the second you lose your focus,
you just can't do it.
All those years I played.
You just play along with,
with like, you know,
playing along with records versus just
being the only person playing is an
entirely different game.
And then if you sit in at a sound
check in the singers not singing,
then you really have to be fucking
paying attention. And uh, yeah,
I just,
once I got past those,
that little fucking shit on the high hat
and the little bottom lik I was like,
Oh man,
it's all fucking downhill from here.
This is all pretty much
straightforward shit. And uh,
oh fucking freckles as always,
at some point whenever I'm,
no matter how well I'm playing,
I always turned back into the Pumpkin,
which I think is apropos considering this
the shape of my head. Um, but anyways,
I want to thank all those guys for letting
me sit in and then they were fucking
amazing. This other guy, salad
and keys, I apologize to, uh,
some of the other people. I mean, there
was like five or six people up there, uh,
another woman, Kayla singing her ass off.
It was, it was fucking awesome, man. And,
uh, I swear to God in another
life, in another life,
the same way I would've done comedy
and continued to sleep on a Futon,
right until my forties, right up to
my forties. Like I basically did.
I would have done that to
try and make it as a drummer.
It's just too much fucking
fun. Um, but anyways,
let's get down to the fucking thing
at hand. I saved to the end. Oh Shit.
Who the fuck wants the football?
Huh? You know the big story?
Tom Brady suspended for four games.
The Baltimore,
that fucking Indianapolis Colts.
What other always be Baltimore to me.
The Indianapolis Colts. Whoa.
A good coach. Air Air out.
That's why we lost by 90 fucking points.
Um,
which really losing by 35 really is
about 70 fucking point. She had dopes.
So anyways, and now we've got our backup
quarterback coming in there. You know,
not only do we win,
the fucking colts lose and you know,
it's the greatest thing about it.
We got another matinee. Idol is a
quarterback. Does that guy look,
he does not have the looks of
a backup quarterback, right?
He looks like the fucking lead and all
those coming of age eighties movies.
The guy who's dating the checked at
the nerd wants to go out with, right?
That fucking guy that says
this, what? Indianapolis.
You never going to understand
our quarterback is better
than your quarterback.
Our backup is better than your
quarterback. They're better looking.
They're better in the clutch.
They got more jewelry over the year.
How do you like dad?
Chimor say,
what the fuck are you going to bitch
about it now? I love it. I love all I'll,
I'll Jimmy has to do is
just get one more victory.
Fucking terrible. Tom Comes
back all fucking, you know,
fucking anger. Snort. None of his fucking
flared out nostrils. A Nice pissed off.
38 year old Tom Brady coming back to fifth
game of the season to get the fucking
Indianapolis Colts,
the old fucking spank and they deserve,
it's going to be tremendous.
I can't fucking wait. Oh,
can you imagine the dream of all dreams
is the Patriots go for no and the
fucking colts go oh and four and then
we hang that fifth loss around their
fucking head and then I guarantee you
there'll be some sort of fucking rule
change spearheaded by Jim
or say I'm telling you the,
the, the, the biggest bullshit
suspension of all fucking time.
Biggest bullshit. Suspense of all time.
Fucking vikings. Heat up the ball.
Get a $50,000. Fine. That's it. Jesus
fucking Christ off poor Tom Brady.
But this is is,
is Matt Nay good looks and his supermodel
wife and is a hundreds of millions of
dollars. This poor bastard
has to sit there and rest.
Oh, he's going to come back fresh
as a daisy. It's going to drive.
It's going to drive cold fence.
Nuts.
Do you have any idea how clear his pores
are going to be having not sweated for
four fucking games? All coat fans a
shit and right now, well it's your dead.
He's going to be rusty.
Tom Bailey.
Rusty is better than any Indianapolis
Colts fucking quarterback in the history
of them being an in Indianapolis.
Now if you want to go back to Baltimore,
they got Johnny Unitas, alright. But
Baltimore is a real fucking football town,
which is why this such Baltimore,
such a great football town,
they accepted the sad sack,
Cleveland browns and the second
day went there. What happened?
The whole fucking thing turned around.
The whole thing turned around.
They got out of the pollution and the
vibe of Cleveland and look what the fuck
happened. You know what I mean? But
there's hope now for the startup.
Cleveland browns. All right,
so to the Gallagher part,
two of the Cleveland Browns,
right?
The ravens sold direct to them.
The original Brown sold direct to
the fucking the junior ones. Right.
And now the Cleveland,
they then,
now they want to fucking championship
right now. All they need.
Like this year I'm jumping on, I've got
to jump on the Fucking Red Sox bandwagon.
This is how much I'm on the bandwagon.
I'm going to name every red sock.
I know right now. All right, big PAPI
in Petrolia.
That's all I fucking know.
I told you like fucking 2010,
you know,
by then like the 90th fucking person had
tested positive for roids and I gave up
on baseball. It was just like, all right,
either fucking make this shit
legal or get it out of the game.
I'm so sick of getting excited about shit.
That's six years you'd tell me
it doesn't really count. So, um,
okay.
You know, this is the best time
of fucking year. I can't wait. Uh,
and my tooth,
my first team is obviously the red
sox and then my second team is the,
uh,
the Cleveland Indians.
And then of course I got to root
for the cubs so I'm not a bad guy.
Roof my own team.
And then whoever's had the longest
fucking drought and root for them.
You can't get mad at that.
I,
I have an idea right now and I don't
even want any money for major league
baseball. I have got an idea. This
is for people like me. All right?
We're all of a sudden your teams
in first place in September.
The only reason why I'm not paying
right now for the MLB package is you're
gonna make me pay for the whole fucking
season.
All right?
This is what you should have
come September 1st. You offer,
uh, you offer the Mlb
Bandwagon bandwagon package.
All right? You charge people for a
month. I mean, I'm telling you right now,
you leaving a bunch of money on the table,
all right?
Cause there's a whole bunch of fucking,
especially if it's a team like the red
sox, they got fans all around the world,
the world, the world,
you know, Yankee fans,
Yankee fans really have fans all
around the world. And I just traveling,
you will always see Yankee gear
the same way. Like over here,
if you're going to see some fucking a
soccer where you're going to see man
United for the longest fucking time.
So the amount of fucking money that you're
leaving on the goddamn table telling
him, just throwing it out there,
the Mlb bandwagon package, you know,
you know what and you let the people
sign up and then what you do is whatever
team they sign up for a is like
a gift. You give them like a, uh,
like a prewarn out baseball hat with
the team logo on it. Like for me,
like a red sox one,
you put like a little salt there.
You don't make it seem like I've been
working out where in this fucking thing
for years when I really just got
it, you know, just a suggestion.
Just throwing it out there. Oh, by the
way, so somebody sent me a great link. Uh,
I should retweet. This is um, you know,
had the origins of all
the NFL football teams.
So I went ahead and looked up the rams.
Now that I brought up that question,
like how do they, how do they become the,
the rams when they started in Cleveland,
there's no rams out there are mountain
sheep, whatever the fuck they call them.
Uh,
just turns out somebody related to the
people that bought the team was a big fan
of this college team. And a lot of
people don't realize this for the first,
like I think decade and a half or so of,
um,
okay.
You know, I mean, a couple of decades
for the first couple of decades,
college football was way bigger than,
than the pros.
The pros was considered boring and that,
and old guys and no one gave a fuck.
And all these colleges because they'd
already been playing there like a 30 year
head start had all these followings
already. I mean, the Ohio State,
Michigan thing was already happening
before the NFL even fucking took a snap,
I believe.
MMM.
Might be wrong on that. It's been a
while since I read up on that shit.
So anyways, um, the way that
they came up with the rams,
there was somebody associated with the
first people that owned that Cleveland
Ram Franchise.
And that person was a big fan of this
college program and football program.
And their,
their mascot was the ramps and they
were very successful and everything.
So they took the same thing.
So that's how you got the Cleveland Rams.
Um,
and by the way,
here's the sad tale of Saint Louis Sports.
All right.
Um,
I read this the other day, so I'm going
off the top of my fucking dumb dumb,
so I might fuck this up.
Saint Louis,
as far as their football goes.
Okay.
They have lost two different
franchises now, but here's the,
here's the reason why they can't be mad.
I'll tell you next time I do a show in St
Louis, this is going to be a rough one,
you know,
is they got the cardinals from Chicago.
Yeah,
Saint Louis Cardinals started in Chicago
and then the now Arizona car started in
Chicago.
And how they became the cardinals was,
they just had these red jerseys and they
said it was a cardinal red and then it
just stuck with them.
But they never put the bird on the side
of the helmet to 1960, believe it or not.
So they started in Chicago.
So this is like when Ray Allen came to
the Celtics and then he left for the heat
and everybody was getting pissed
in Boston. Like, Oh, what the fuck?
That guy's a trade. It's like, dude,
that's how we got this guy. All right.
If you sign a free agent, it
just put, as a sports fan,
you have to understand that's
like dating a stripper. All right?
Don't fucking get too emotionally
involved in that person. All right?
That person has figured out that sports
at the professional level is just that
it's a fucking business
so they don't give a fuck.
They're going to bounce
around the God damn leak.
MMM.
So anyways, stay. They fucking started
in Chicago, moved to Saint Louis,
was there from like 1960 or something
like that in 1950 [inaudible] to 1987.
Okay.
Then they left.
Then they got the Saint Louis Rams in
1996 and they stayed there for 20 seats.
Uh, 20 years. 21 seasons, and then
they went back to la. All right.
An La got 'em from fucking Cleveland.
So La couldn't get mad because
you got them for Cleveland.
Saint Louis can't be mad that they went
back to la cause you got them from La,
you know this,
these are these StreetEasy,
these hoary stripper fucking franchises,
which why it would be so fucking perfect
if Oakland ends up in Las Vegas much to
their fans,
sorrow.
I mean that's one of the biggest hoary
franchise of all fucking time where the
Oakland Raiders as well. We're
going to move to la. It's
better here. Oh fuck this.
Oh we get take us back Oakland.
And they do with open arms.
Oakland went back in with open
fucking arbs and look at them now.
Now they're talking about how they're
going to fucking move to Vegas.
That's a travesty, man.
That is a fucking travesty.
I think that the city of Oakland ought
to be able to retain the rights to that
fucking logo because that's the best logo,
best uniform.
Certainly in football, if
not all a sports. And um,
yeah, somehow retain it the way the
fucking brown state. It's like, all right,
you want to fuck you Cleveland
fans too. It's like, all right,
you want to fucking go to Vegas? Yeah,
go be the be the fucking Vegas gamblers,
you know? Um, you know,
but NFL would do that because they're
so fucking pure, even though they, I,
you know,
it's funny,
I can't even remember the name of that
fucking gambling site that they were in
bed with last year.
Was it daily something or other
draft kings. Remember those
guys? Everybody fucking
walked away from that shitter.
Um, because everybody bitched at the state
level. They're like, hey, you're cured.
You're gambling in our state. This, we
don't approve of that. You have, fuck you,
you don't approve it.
This is all those kids that draft kings
fucked up is they didn't give everybody
a taste. If they gave everybody a
little taste off the Skimm like casino,
give them the skim, every state would have
been fucking fine with it. But anyway,
so getting back to St Louis,
so they've had two s sports franchises.
They've never had their own,
though.
They were never awarded a
fucking franchise, which I'm,
I'm calling right now is going to
happen maybe in the next 20 years.
When all freckles is 68,
closing in on 70.
Still doing pullups
still doing the podcast,
still yelling at his fucking whatever
the fuck it is at that the computer chip
in his head at that point.
Right.
I think that they're gonna build a
fucking state of the art stadium and they
finally going to get their
own fucking franchise.
Okay. Not some, not some
fucking, uh, you know,
you know, in some retread or some
bullshit like that, right? Some old shoe,
you put a new sole on, fuck that.
They're getting a brand new one. Um,
so then you move to that basketball,
they had the saint Louis Hawks,
right,
who I want to say won a championship.
I know we beat them in the NBA finals
and like 58 or something like that.
They fucking move to Atlanta.
So they've lost one basketball team.
They lost to fucking football teams.
And then he,
that brings us to the Saint Louis browns.
The Saint Louis Browns were
initially were designated,
I guess to be in Saint Louis,
but for whatever fucking
reason they played one lame
duck year in the early like
1900 or something like that.
1899 assumption. Like I said,
I read all of this stuff a few days ago.
It's not like I'm some fucking,
I don't take it to this level, but it
just, for me, it was interesting to me,
they fucking played in 1,901 season lame
duck in Milwaukee and weren't actually
called the brewers.
Like I don't know how many years before
the Seattle pilots moved over there and
became the brewers. I believe that's who
they were before that. That was like,
and I don't know what the fuck that was,
the sixties early seventies but anyways,
they were the brewers for one year and
then they moved to St Louis and became
the Saint Louis Browns and I forget
what the fuck they were named after a,
they took the name from something else
so that they actually one point had two
teams. They had the Saint Louis Cardinals,
which is still there, thank God. Right.
And then they had the Saint Louis
Proud to Saint Louis Browns,
eventually moved to Baltimore and became
the second coming of the Baltimore
Orioles. Cause the first port of
Baltimore Oriole team moved to New York,
was called the New York islanders.
And then they became the New York Yankees.
Believe it or not, they originally
from fucking Baltimore Self.
That brings us back to Saint Louis.
All right.
The Saint Louis Baseball cardinals
and the St Louis Blues. All right.
That stuff that has to be the heart
of the city. Even though, you know,
the St Louis Blues had been breaking
their fucking arts every year. They still,
you still got a level right.
And the cardinals,
other than the Yankees have the most,
the most championships with like 11.
How fucking nuts is that?
That's the closest team to the Yankees.
It's still 16 a decade and a half
of winning straight plus one year.
Um, no wait, is that
right? Yeah, yeah. Anyways.
Um,
so they've lost two football teams,
a basketball team in a baseball team.
They've lost four fucking teams.
Okay. And I'm trying to have
empathy for the Saint Louis Fan,
but at some point people of Saint Louis,
you gotta be looking at yourself and you
got to start asking the right questions.
Like,
what am I bringing to the table?
What am I not bring it to the table that
is making this franchise turn around
and look up in the stands and be like, we
gotta get the Fuck Outta here. You know,
you've got no one to blame but yourself,
Saint Louis not fucking with you. Um,
it sucks.
Hopefully they'll get their own,
they'll get their own franchise
some day. They deserve it. Right?
I would think so. Like the level of
hockey fan and baseball fan. I mean,
Saint Louis Fans, people, uh,
routinely say are the greatest
baseball fans out there, you know,
as knowledgeable as Boston, red
sox fans without a, what's up g?
It's going on, don't you feeling all right
buddy. None and none of the aggression,
you know. Um, so anyways,
so that should be enough time,
right? Oh Geez. I did 40 minutes.
They did a little overtime for you there.
Um,
I want to say there was one of the
things I wanted to talk about. Oh, so I,
I watched the first rams game.
I've decided that, uh, I'm gonna,
you know, I'm going, I'm going to root
for the ramps that they're out. I mean,
I'm Patriots Fan, but like I'm going
to watch them out here because, uh,
it's cool man. There in the division
with the cardinals, 40 niners Seattle,
I never get to watch this division.
It's fucking great. And uh,
I was sick of watching charger games
for God's sakes. Jesus fucking Christ,
you know, this is certain diseases,
certain level of fucking uh,
masochism you have to have to be
a fucking San Diego charger fan.
I don't know what the fuck they did.
I don't know if that stadium is built
on an old native American grave site.
I don't know what the fuck those people
ever got. Dad Did. But Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ,
not only the way they lose the way they
just rip those people and maybe they're
just paying the price for the absolute
most perfect weather in the United States.
San Diego, something has to give. What
do you want? You want perfect weather,
three 65 or you want fucking 16 Sundays,
you know of right there Fred.
You know what I mean?
That didn't make sense.
I'm saying you the tradeoff,
the tradeoff is you get the
old right there, Fred for
16 Sundays out of the year,
three 65 minus 16 is
three 49 of beautiful,
of absolute fucking beauty.
Most people would take that.
Certainly not sports fans. All right, I
think I'm done here. Yeah. That rams camp,
Jesus Christ. Was that a fucking, was
that brutal of what Steve Young said?
The funniest shit. And if you guys caught
a right before halftime, he goes, uh, he,
they showed, I guess, um,
the rams have some high level
draft pick or something like that.
Or are they traded for somebody?
It's like a backup quarterback or some
kid just learn it. And Steve Young's like,
yeah, he's going to stand
there on the sideline, you
know, hold a clipboard and a,
you know, just watch and try and learn,
you know, and then he paused and he goes,
I don't know what he's learned.
Yeah.
Tonight.
I can't believe the only had 85 yards
of total offense, something like that.
It seemed to me like they add a little
more than that, but um, whatever.
So I'm happy. Philosophy. Angela, she
finally got NFL football back here.
My condolences to St Louis,
but I'm calling it right now.
Putting the good vibes out there.
The next time you get your own.
Not a fucking retread.
Not the Jacksonville Jaguars.
Moving in at the fucking Oakland Raiders.
Fuck Vegas. We're going to Saint Louis.
You're going to get your own.
And what would you, what would you call
it? Give it a nice, good Midwestern name.
Why don't you do what are ready. Come
on, give me, send me some good names.
Saint Louis. Ah, jeepers creepers. Right?
You guys are so fucking
wholesome out there yet. Still
racist as any other place,
but you're just so fucking wholesome.
All right, that's, that's the, uh,
I was just checking in on you. Who's
getting, who have a great weekend?
You can't a joy. The music.
I don't pick it out. Um,
and with feminists the great
with and with demos does so, uh,
tweeted him or the or at
the and podcast and uh,
we're also going to play a half hour of,
uh,
some clips from a podcast
Monday or a Thursday.
Gone Pass. Go fuck yourselves.
Enjoy the news. Oh wait,
I got to do the advertising
here it comes from advertising.
Oh,
gimme the Lou Lou crate.
Everybody looking for gear,
collectibles,
houseware and more from your
favorite pop culture franchises.
What we got you covered.
Fucko Lou crate offers a range of Geek
and Gamer items for less than 20 bucks a
month. Want to bring you
a loot to the next level?
Motherfucker get a bigger box with an
even bigger lute with loot crate DX.
Um, if you're more the type to where your
heart on your sleeve, then loot. Ugh,
I hate people to do that.
Then loop where they sit Indian style.
It's almost like they're daring
to get the shit kicked out of him.
You know what I mean?
And you know what to bring an
old tried and true thing back,
they're asking for it.
Then Lewd,
where our monthly wearables and
accessories subscription is.
What you're looking for. Get ready for
September is high octane themes. Speed.
This month's loot crate has a high
octane assortment of goodies from Batman,
CWS, the flash and arrow. Now
way not CW. Who the fuck is that?
Battlestar Galactica,
ironman and gone in 60 seconds.
If you have stopped a style need,
you'll love our speed loot.
Where collection featuring sonic socks
for when you got to go fast. What
are these people? Five years old,
they socks in my fist.
A transformers wearable for your world
saving needs and a winning Mario Kart.
T and more. This loot where collection
is going to zoom away quick.
Uh, you have until the
19th at 9:00 PM Pacific.
Are they trying to give
these people more acne,
new to subscribe and receive that month's
crate? And when the cutoff happens,
that's it.
It's over.
Make sure to head to www dot [inaudible]
dot com slash burr and enter code burr
to save $3 off on any new subscription.
A look who's back booboo.
Boop, boop, me undies,
me undies dressed in like iron man,
Blue Doo Doo Doo me undies,
me undies. Uh, how fried in a pan?
I don't know people. It's
fucking late. All right.
Stick your balls and a souffle
whip 'em out and then you say, hey,
there's still edible. They only if
you're a chick and maybe if you bisexual,
who knows?
They even make them for the ladies
to draw their privates. All right?
Whether you're wearing a suit or sweats,
he spent almost 24 hours a day in
your underwear unless you're like Jake
Gyllenhaal, one of people
magazine's 50 most beautiful people.
Who is that guy who keeps fucking like
just kayak and naked Orlando Bloom.
Jesus Christ the fuck.
Why would you do that?
You know, they fucking call these people.
My Twitter followers are going down.
I'm going to show my hairy ass crack on
my fucking surf board paddle thing there.
That's the technical name for it.
The surfboard.
Pettaway he needs some fucking me undies,
but instead of making a statement
like superman and his tights under his
everyday clothes,
your underwear's probably boring me.
UNDIES is here to change that.
Please include all I'm gone. I,
if you fucking send them to me,
I'll read it.
Every pair of me undies is made from
sustainable source modal filing.
Learned how to say it. Muddle of
fabric. That's twice as soft as cotton.
Nothing can describe the fit and feel of
me undies yet the copy, we'll continue,
but for once.
But once you try them,
you'll understand why they're called
the world's world's world's most
comfortable underwear,
underwear.
And if you don't love your first
pair of me undies, they're free.
No questions asked me. Andy
says, does well, what are
they going to take them back
in a washing machine
and sent them out again?
Me and he says dozens of styles and
limited edition prints to help you make a
statement with your underwear. Remember
whether anyone could see them or not.
Remember Superman. A okay. Shipping
in the U s is free and Canada.
You can save up to eight bucks a pair
with me undies subscription plan.
You get the subscription
off a sink or a single pair.
Get 20% off your first order when you
go to [inaudible] dot com slash bird
that's [inaudible] dot com slash burr
for your 20% off your first order. Hey,
Johnny's dot com slash burr
then next, why don't you sit in like
that cause it's cause it's boring. Copy.
All right everybody. Here we go. Your
favorites. You have a favorite in mind.
The new head of the advertising.
It's our good old friends, old zip.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your
job to find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place.
Oh that's not enough to find
quality candidates. What do we do?
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post all your jobs in
the top job sites and now you can
with zip recruiter.com you can post
your job to 100 plus job sites,
including social media networks
like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Holy Shit.
Find candidates with their
titties out on Instagram.
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your
qualified candidates roll into zip.
Easy to use interface.
No juggling emails or
calls to your office.
Quickly screen candidates.
Rate them and hire the right person fast,
man.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has
been used by over 800,000 businesses and
right now my listeners can post on job
jobs on Ziprecruiter for free by going to
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's
ziprecruiter.com/burr one
more time to try it free.
Go to zip.
Slash birth
please.
You know a few weeks ago somebody
was asking me, Oh, you know,
they wanted to break up with somebody and
I was saying, listen, you gotta listen.
You know,
the person who has it down how to do
the breakup was minivan men podcast,
own celebrity star Al Madrigal.
But if you don't have
time to email Al Madrigal
just listening to ll cool j a big old,
but
I don't know why. I never really listened
to him when I was growing up. You know,
Mama said knock you out. Oh,
did chic? Is that what she said?
Ll Cool J I don't care. You
know, I just wasn't into it.
And his deodorant and his armpits when
he was jamming with those white guys.
I just, I never got into
it. But lately, lately,
I dunno. I Dunno what
happened. I, Geez, just come
onto my youtube shit.
I don't know what it is,
but I was listening to some
of his stuff. Oh, I know why.
Yesterday I was trying to remember like,
what was that song he used to have that
I'm the type of guy and you're the type
of guy,
but what the fuck was that?
And then I listened to it and I kind
of liked it, but I hated that. Oh,
we owe part of it really
annoyed me. I'm like, oh,
that's why I never downloaded this shit.
But then on the side they
had a ll cool j big old,
but you know, I play drums at Michael.
Let me hear what this track sounds like.
Can I put it on?
And he basically teaches you how to
break up with a girl and that song,
but that rap or that, uh, that rhyme,
whatever, however you supposed to say it,
he breaks it down and just
in like fucking 11 seconds,
he sits his girls down.
He's basically hanging out and like some
sunglass hut or some shit and some girl
comes in with an insane ass and
he does what every guy does.
He stares at and he thinks I want to fuck
that. But Oh shit, I have a girlfriend.
So what does he do? Does
he sneak around on her? No,
he goes home and he sits her
down and he says, listen,
I met this girl named Tina.
Okay. Tina's got a big old,
but I know that I said I'd
be true really whiteness up.
But Tina a big old butt.
So I'm leaving you. It's,
I mean that's just fucking air tight.
You can't fuck with that.
He was 100% I don't know. She
could get mad. I think that's that.
I think women's show expect guys to be
lion weaselly pieces of shit that if you
actually hit him with
that level of honesty,
I think they would just be stunned.
Just like the check in the video.
Like I didn't think that
that was bad acting.
I think that they would absolutely be
stunned if you just came home and said,
listen,
I met this girl.
I know that I said it'd be faithful to
you, but she's better looking than you,
so I'm breaking up with you.
Oh well what is the comeback?
There's nothing that'd be like if
your girl came home and said, listen,
I know we're together,
but this guy,
you know I met him at the mall is Dick
is twice the size of yours and he's got a
better car. So it's kind
of a no brainer. Amati
what are you going to do?
What are you gonna do with your little
dick in your fucking Domino's pizza?
It's over. You just got to fucking be
like, you know, you only go around once.
So, uh, yeah, I, I, I get it.
So anyway, so if you don't have
time to a email Al Madrigal,
which you should,
which you should just listen
to a ll cool j big old bud.
You got to see his face when he
goes. So I'm leaving you. It's,
it's w I don't, can't explain it.
It's way meaner than it has to be.
That's what it makes it funny
cause there's a way to read that where
you're kind of letting them down easily,
you know, but he, then he
just did it like, yeah,
this is how it works. So they,
you'd go look at that on a holiday.
Um, anyways, this is the Monday morning
podcast. It is the end of May. Everybody.
All right.
How many days are in May?
30 days has September sodas,
April and November.
All the rest have a bunch of other
dates except for February. Yeah.
Go Fuck yourself with your song.
Um,
so you got 30 31 fuck, what is it?
April has 30 June has 30 maze.
31 I got the little thing.
I can click right here. Oh,
I have a computer. I don't
need to think right. It has.
Why is it in September?
Oh, for Christ sake,
do I have to click another button?
It has 31 days.
All right,
so you had till have you guys have until
Thursday midnight to make something of
May, 2012 all right, are you
on a fucking relationship?
You don't want to be in?
Do you want to be in this?
You don't want to be in,
in June.
Why don't you celebrate the end of
May by getting out of your fucking
relationship and sitting down
and basically just go
with the ll cool j vibe.
Hold her hand and just go straight up
honesty and then what she going to do.
But what's he going to do if
they're going to flip the fuck out,
but the the die has been
cast to ship is said sale.
The ball is already rolling, the
sun is setting, the rain has fallen.
Whatever the fuck you want to call it.
It's out there. Just put it out there.
Let them scream and yell.
And in your head as much as it sucks,
you're going to be like,
okay, I did it. I did it.
Now I just got to sit here
and get yelled at and uh,
how long could somebody really yelled
before they lose their voice? An hour,
90 minutes and an hour and a half.
I'm going to be in the car listening to
ll cool j driving away from that thing I
didn't want to be in. All right then.
I know I talk about this shit a lot,
but I think a lot of people
are in situations like this
and they don't know how
to sit. Somebody dumb it
just say, so I'm leaving you.
Yeah.
You know, if I was ll cool
J and I stop, you know,
selling tickets and all that type of shit,
that would be a side business
that I would have. I would take,
okay,
that little fucking rhyme that he had
and I would custom do it for everybody in
their life and just, and then people
could just write you all right,
I need to charge it. You charge them 100
bucks and he would write you a, you know,
four bars.
It all rhymes and you just get out exactly
what you say it,
you know.
Okay.
Just be like you eat with your mouth
open. I know I said that. That'd be true.
But you eat with your mouth open so
I'm leaving you. It just get right.
You just get right down to it.
Your mom is a fucking con.
I know,
I said I'd be true,
but she's fucking always coming over
here and something that rhymes with Katya
and I, you got, you got the idea by Jesus
Christ. What am I going to be yellow?
One
thing was missing.
Oh my God.
Here's one for you guys.
My boyfriend wants to have his
four skin restored. By the way,
how fresh and new are these,
uh, these emails here?
Just because it's coming from the female
perspective. I love this shit. All right,
that's saying,
I don't want guys to email it,
but I would like to have a nice balance
here. I already say enough shit.
Trash and women. So it helps if women
come and trash and guys, because,
uh, I, you know, it'll, it'll be
a nice balance here. All right.
My boyfriend wants to have his
for skin restored. Dear bill,
I wanted to get your take on a situation
I'm in with my current boyfriend. Uh,
I'm a girl. All right. A few weeks ago,
my boyfriend of two years told me
that he's become totally upset that he
circumcised and wants to restore his for
skin via taping and stretching methods.
What,
and basically why he wants to do this
is because everybody, they say that, um,
intercourse you, you lose like, I don't
know, some percentage of sensitivity
when you have,
you're forced skin removed and um,
okay.
All I can say is no guy can tell the
difference whether he has a four skin or
whether he doesn't.
Because unless you got laid when
you were fucking six weeks old,
you don't know what you're
gaining or what you're missing.
So I don't understand
why you would do this.
So t by restore his forced can via
taping and stretching methods, she goes,
I know, I know. It makes me want
to throw up just thinking about it.
I want him to tell him, I
think he's out of his mind. Uh,
but I don't want to hurt his feelings.
The thing is,
I'm totally grossed out by the idea
of for skin penises are gross enough
already. There's no need to make
it even grosser. Uh, you know,
what am I the only guy that
totally agrees with that?
Is there anything more fucking disgusting?
Then I'll fucking flacid
for skin covered dish.
I didn't know what it looks like.
Yeah,
it looks like I got a fucking,
I don't know what it looks like.
I, it's, it's just fucking disgusting.
I don't even have like a reference.
Looks like an Elephant Dick. I don't
even know what to say. It's just gross.
It's fucking disgusting. Um, she goes,
obviously I can't tell him how I feel.
He's clearly having a
really hard time with this.
He tells me that he feels violated
and disfigured. This guy's a pussy,
this throat, this throw this
guy into the fucking pussy, Ben,
and get on with your life.
He also claims that for skins has a
lot of advantage for both partners,
but it's hard for me to totally buy that
considering the fact I have slept with
a couple uncircumcised guy and I
didn't notice any extra pleasure.
Although I did use a condom
with both guys. Yeah,
he's full of Shit. He's full of Shit.
It may be more pleasure for him.
I don't know what I mean.
I think it's amazing that women will
put a dick in their mouths, you know?
At least you can do is try and tidy up
down there. You know? How about happened?
Little fucking empathy.
Okay.
I've asked you this discussion.
It's just fucking extra skin. Yeah.
Nothing more sexy or then
extra skin. Yeah. Yeah.
It's like your Dick used to be
obese and then lost a ton of weight,
but didn't have enough money to have
that surgery. They get rid of the extra.
Ah, that's gross. There's
another two paragraphs,
people just just preparing you for
another two paragraphs of having an
uncircumcised stretch taped
dick in your head. Anyway,
I think it's absolutely disgusting and
totally weird that he wants to do this
and I'm starting to get really turned off
by the idea of sleeping with him while
he's stretching out. As for good,
he told me he's going to tape it
okay.
To an elastic strap,
which is going to tie around his leg.
I know. What the fuck is he just
coming up with this shit on his own.
I told him that he should see a
doctor before he starts to do this,
but he doesn't want,
but he doesn't think that doctors know
much about this sort of thing. Oh,
so he's just going to take it in his
own hands. Congratulations sweetheart.
You're dating a fucking moron.
Okay,
come on. This is the
father. You had children?
Yeah.
Coming up with, you know, taking an
erector set to his fucking Dick. It was,
it's the you.
Yeah.
Do I have to finish reading this?
I'm thinking of breaking it off
with them really. Course you are.
I thought he was a normal guy,
but I had no idea he had all this freaky
shit going on underneath the surface.
Anyways.
What do you think about all of this?
You got to go ll cool J.
Yeah,
it's got to do what he did.
Okay.
You're stretching out your fucking
Dick. I know. I said I'd be true.
You're stretching out your fucking Dick.
So I'm leaving you go fuck yourself.
It's over. Yeah. Fucking gross.
Anyway, what do you think? All this,
am I justified dumping him away or would
that make me an insensitive comment?
No,
it would make you as strong person.
Okay.
All right.
You go with your gut on this one.
Yeah.
This guy is trying to to
do the impossible, like,
uh, like he said, fucking
scientist in that Michael J.
Fox movie back to the future.
Okay.
He's basically,
you know,
doing the Delorean bullshit with his Dick
and he doesn't want to go see a doctor.
Any doctor would tell them,
you can't do that.
Okay.
You'll be funny though,
was if you dumped this guy right,
and it actually works and then he starts
screaming like Billy Mays on TV with
his, his Dick Stretcher
and he sells it for 1995.
It makes a zillion dollar. I'm just
playing devil's advocate here. You know,
there's a 99% chance you're
doing the right thing,
but there is a 1% chance you
could be walking away from a,
a potential millionaire.
Cause I gotta be honest with you,
if that guy actually pulls this off,
no pun intended,
he pulls this off.
Okay.
And he's able to do it with some
household material and then he,
you know, Pete, they already make
millions of dollars with those,
those pills that say they're
going to make your Dick Bigger,
which we all know it doesn't
work because of it fucking work.
That would be an international story.
And um,
and then it still wouldn't work because
then what would happen was everybody
would take big dick pills,
even guys with big dicks because they
don't want everybody else catching up with
them.
So then having a little dick would
then be like having a six inch dick as
opposed to a three inch,
four inch Dick. Right.
Okay.
It's a math workout on that or get bumped
up. You've got to six, seven inch Dick.
He just, he just regular, no,
you're actually not regular. Yeah,
you'd have a little Dick.
Okay,
so if this guy actually
fucking is able to pull this,
that doesn't even make sense.
He's going, he, if he
thought he was disfigured,
now wait till he tries to fucking do this.
I mean his dick is going to look like,
you know when those people
put that shit their ear lobes.
Okay.
They put those fucking,
those circular circular things.
You could shoot a God damn fucking bow
and Arrow through somebody's ear lobe and
not drawing any blood.
He's going to do that to his deck except
he's not going to have that thing in
there and he's just going to be
hanging out. Wrightsville we got it.
It's disgusting.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 25th could you hear me
looking for the date there?
I kind of like was looking and I,
June 25th June 25th and this,
sorry. I'm actually excited
because doing it Sunday night,
so this fucking thing is going to be
up at midnight west coast time in the
continental United States, which means
I don't have to deal with anybody,
you know, giving me shit. Yeah.
They went to fleck. You know what?
What the fuck right back at you.
I'm going to Greg.
Goddamn move my Lady Lady.
You have left this state and I am all
alone now and I'm remembering what it was
like.
Okay.
Oh Man.
I just made my freckled ass
so motherfucking chicken.
I had boneless id bone,
those thighs too,
like a motherfucker. I'm a
such a stupid move. I A had a,
had boneless chicken breasts.
No boneless chicken thighs.
Um, and brought Brock. Sorry,
I can't say that word without, I can't
say Broccoli without a, an Asian accent.
I don't know why.
I know why.
Because when I lived in New
York City and I was broke,
there was a Chinese restaurant around
the corner and I always ordered chicken
and Broccoli. Okay. If I wasn't
eating sketti with fucking Prego,
I would call up every once in a while.
I would treat myself with little
Chinese food and I would call up.
They like hello, number one.
I'm like, Hey, number one,
what's up? Can I get a good,
I get chicken and Broccoli.
They made chicken, Broccoli.
And ever since that I've said that.
So just in case you thought I had
any, uh, Chinese blood in me, I don't,
I consider those people, my friends
for all the chicken, Broccoli,
they made me back in the late 90.
So sounds like an apology.
Like a corporate apology.
I had no dealings with
number one Chinese food.
Uh, I did stop in there
on a number of occasions.
I did partake in some of the
cuisine that was offered,
but at no time was there any inappropriate
touching underneath that filthy
fucking glass that I don't
think it was bulletproof.
You know,
I'll tell you the Chinese restaurants in
fucking New York where I lived anyways
when I was on the upper east side,
Jesus Christ, you know what I mean?
It was like you'd have some either
it was either rusty, rusty, great.
Between you and the other person or
just filthy glass plastic or some shit.
I Dunno. Why don't I don't, oh Christ.
I don't even know what I'm saying.
Look at my dog. Just fucking
lay in there. Can you,
can he get a God damn job and you know,
contribute.
Okay.
Actually Jealous. Thanks. Fucking
skinny as hell dude with dogs.
Emaciated. Dropped her off at the trainer.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Yeah, we'll be, what were you
doing over there? All right, let's,
let's get the podcast. Let's get
it. Let's get it back under control.
I didn't do shit to this anyways,
so my woman's out of town. My Lady,
she's out of town. So, uh, you know what's
funny is she keeps checking in on me.
You know, what are you doing?
What's going on? You know,
and you don't want it is,
it's one because she misses me into,
because they think that we're fucking
morons and she just wants to hear.
I like how, what a difficult time
I'm having without her, you know,
like, ah, I don't really
know how to make cereal like,
like I'm some Sitcom fucking
guy. All right? It's not,
I was going down. I did the fucking
laundry. I made myself a healthy dinner.
A protein, no bigger than the size of my
head. Isn't that what we supposed to eat?
And uh, in some fun. A
vegetable. All right,
go fuck yourself if you know what,
I had a great time doing it.
I haven't cooked in years.
And you know why?
Because my woman is
oppressive in the kitchen.
She loves cooking. So anytime I
go to cook, she comes in there.
She's looking over my fucking shoulder.
Just why you kind of come up that way.
Why don't you think you're like, I
fucking fuck you. You fucking do it. Why?
I'm fucking trying to
make you a God damn meals.
One of the nicest thing somebody can
do for you. Prepare a meal for you.
Just sit there. Shut the fuck up and let
me do you think. What do you think I did?
800 800 gut damn garbage
kids before I met you.
She just gives me shit about the way I
make my eggs because she, you know, we,
he says, I always, whenever I
make scrambled eggs or whatever,
like there's too much egg gets stuck to
the fucking pan and it's a pain in the
ass to watch, to wash. I
mean, you know, it's like,
I'm sorry I don't spray it with,
you know, fuck the ozone layer Pam.
Every God damn time dripping with
the shit and when it doesn't stick,
I'm surprised it doesn't fucking slide
right off onto the floor. This is,
you know what,
this is what,
this year just listening to a pathetic
man whose site that he's finally in his
place by himself and he can just deliver
his entire argument without being
interrupted. So, uh, I'm telling you,
she wants to come back and as much
as she wants the place to be neat,
she wants it to be a fucking disaster.
She wants to feel needed.
She wants to feel that I am fucking
lost without her and I'm such a cunt.
I am not going to let that happen.
This place is going to be spotless.
It's going to be ready for one
of those movie drill sergeants.
You know those guys that get in your face,
you know he can come over here and
bounce a fucking quarter right off my God
damn face ever.
Whatever the fuck they do off the beds.
She's the very thing I wouldn't
ever make it in the military.
I'm supposed to be able to
bounce a fucking court. Why?
Why you supposed to be
able to bounce a quarter?
Why does that somehow make me uh,
you know better at fighting the enemy.
If I can throw dirty change
at a blanket and then,
and then catch it like the fonts.
You know, what happened to you sir?
What did you really want to do? Get? Oh,
did you really want to do this
and scream at Pete? That was your,
that was your dream to scream at
people for your entire fucking life.
That's what you wanted to do
with that Hitler Fade.
Do you know Hitler had like a fresh
prince from Bel Air Haircut mixed with a
Martin Sheen in apocalypse. He was
Martin Sheen, apocalypse now on top.
But he had like,
he had a fade down below that,
that will Smith's character with the
eight ball leather jacket would have,
would have loved you would've loved it.
I'm sorry.
I've been watching a lot of shit about
fucking mass murderer lately and he
always comes up. Of course.
You know what I mean?
Gay and have a think about mass
murders without Hitler, right?
Just can't fucking do it.
Can't have a rock show without Zeplin
man, stairway to heaven. You know,
that's what it is. You got to fucking
ham. That shit in there. So I'm,
so that's my goal. That's my goal.
And I'm actually wrestling with this.
Should I leave the place a little bit
dirty so she feels like wanted or should I
be, should I just go
fucking like, you know,
just come with the pimp vibe.
Like this place is fucking spotless.
All right? So you need to be on
Umi. Need to mind your p's and q's.
Whatever the fuck those letters stand for,
what does it stand for?
Somebody is going to know somebody
actually knows what, when you know,
when you say mind your p's and q's,
there's some Douche. Listen to this. Yeah,
you're a dose.
All right.
That knows what the fuck that stands
for and they've just been waiting for
somebody. You'll fuck it up all excited
so they can be like, I know what it means.
Well,
send me a god damn email and by the way,
I haven't said the email for a
while here. Oh, what a segue.
Fucking classic right there.
I should teach a fucking podcast class.
Uh,
you know somebody's going to do that.
Someone's got to teach a podcast class
the same way somebody teach a comedy
class and that's what you
do when you're failing.
Whenever you're failing at what you do,
you teach it. All right, there we go.
We just insulted teachers. Um, all right,
the email is bill@themmpodcast.com.
Bill at the capital m,
capital m,
capital P odcast.com bill at
the end, podcast.com. All right.
If you don't fucking know what it by now,
just hit stop and rewind on your
little player and you'll be fine.
Um, oh, by the way, can you guys, I know,
I really appreciate all the input and
all that stuff that you guys send to me
because God knows if he
didn't send it to me,
I wouldn't be able to do this podcast.
See without you,
I'm nothing is,
they slowly dim the lights and I go
into some sort of pandering fucking song
like that Jackson Browne song singing
about the roadies. Like he gives a shit,
you know,
I think he fucking pissed them off and
they weren't set in his piano upright.
So he wrote them a song just so they
stopped fucking with them so he could get
worried of his tour and then
somehow he goes out of that. Right?
Just fucking the whole thing is,
I hate pandering.
I don't like it.
And you know,
the only one of the worst
part of pandering is watching
a performer go on stage
and pander to the audience is watching
you fucking animals. Eat it up.
Eat it up every God damn time,
okay?
I go to jail. You Sob did we played
a lot of cities but Hartford,
you guys,
you guys are the best in every way.
Okay?
Give me a fucking break.
There's nothing good about Hartford.
Okay?
You know, you don't believe me? Ask The
whalers. Why do you think they left?
You couldn't even hold onto the fucking
whalers. How does that make you feel?
Hard for too.
Okay.
You know why they left? Because
that's stupid ass song. You
splay. Bam, Bam, Bam, Bam.
What's it called? The the,
the brass city orchestra.
[inaudible]
good.